il y a deux choses la première c'est
comment finalement la question de la
parentalité les difficultés qui sont
liées au sujet concerne toutes les
couches de la société toutes les classes
socioprofessionnelles ce n'est pas lié
en fait à la capacité de chacun de gérer
la séparation ou le divorce
malheureusement mais c'est c'est un
problème qui concerne tout le monde et
la seconde c'est la capacité en fête des
papas de lâcher prise sur situation
surtout quand ça fait mal c'est à dire
que des fois il gère la situation avec
force il a géré aussi avec avec
tristesse parfois et ça vient finalement
affecté la relation encore plus puisque
il souffre de la condamnation il souffre
de la situation de conflit et des fronts
au fait qu'ils arrivent à faire preuve
de lâcher prise et ça permet d'ouvrir le
débat de raisonner aussi parfois parce
que voilà on arrive à des situations par
un peu extraordinaire
ce qui m'a le plus touché c'est comment
finalement le jour de l'anniversaire des
enfants plusieurs papas se sont
retrouvés à attendre
1h 2h 3h toute une journée en bas de la
maison en bas de la salle d'anniversaire
enfin bref
et ce n'est pas une situation isolée
mais c'est une situation que plusieurs
ont connu et voilà ce sont des choses en
fait qui viennent
des fois les anéantir tout simplement et
puis nous et ça ne l'a pas pas mon
essaye finalement dans le cadre
d'ateliers d'échangés tout ça de
permettre de se retrouver et de faire un
partage d'expérience pour que chacun
trouve décrit dans le témoignage de
l'autre